plenty for us to get stuck into as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
these are the days that we dread this
morning's tragedy
like the loss of 27 people on One
November Day last year
is the most sobering reminder possible
of why we have to end these Crossings
well that was the Home Secretary sueller
Brotherman to a somber House of Commons
her statement came just after a far more
cognitive pmqs which was focused on
strikes
in 12 hours time there's a nurses strike
all he needs to do is meet the nurses
his inaction speaks volumes as ever with
this prime minister it's Tory politics
first patient second well the opposition
leader kirst armor make it clear who he
blames for the strikes but Rishi sunak
was also quick to exploit any
awkwardness that labor might feel over
the subject
if he thinks it's right that pay demands
of 19 are met then he should say so
what what's weak Mr Speaker is he's not
strong enough to stand up to the union
well with major strikes and everything
from Rail and mail to the NHS and more
on almost every day of this month it's a
subject that we're likely to be
discussing for a while yet and as it's
our very last program of the year we're
going to be asking our panel to reflect
on an extraordinary 12 months in
politics and to give us their politician
over the years so it'll be interesting
to hear their choices we've also got
some top guests for you including the
Royal College of Nursing General
Secretary Pat Cullen for the government
will talk to the health minister at
Maria Caulfield and we'll also be
talking to Labor's Shadow Financial
secretary to the treasury James Murray
much more besides on the tech
[Applause]
foreign
Minister Rishi sunak expressed his
sorrow at the deaths in the English
Channel today Sue Ella ratherman called
it a day we dread so far we know that
four people have died but others do
remain in hospital almost 50 people were
rescued in the bitter cold and dark of
the early hours when their small boat
capsized meanwhile the first ever strike
in the 106 year history of the Royal
College of Nursing will go ahead
tomorrow so let's crack straight on
shall we we're going to start with the
most important stories of the week so
far
specialist police divers have been
searching through the night at a
freezing Lake in solihull near
Birmingham four children were pulled
from the water one of my officers was
trying to punch through the ice to to
actually rescue the the children
themselves three of the four boys who
were pulled from the lake have very
sadly died a major row has erupted
between the government and trade unions
over exactly who's to blame for the
winter strikes I went into that room
today with hopes uh obviously and came
out with another one single Brown Penny
20 of train services are running today
there is a way forward the government's
got to facilitate that show a good bit
of good Wheels I think the tide is
turning on opinion about whether these
offers are reasonable or not right now
look private sector wages going up
really high public sector quite weak in
terms of wage inflation and we are
staying with our breaking news that
three people have died and at least 43
have been rescued after a major incident
in the channel these are the days that
we read this morning's tragedy
is the most sobering reminder possible
of why we have to end these crossings
they did the opposition kill Starman
all he needs to do is meet the nurses as
ever with this prime minister it's Tory
politics first patient second if he
thinks it's right that pay demands of 19
are met then he should say so
what what's weak Mr Speaker is he's not
strong enough to stand up to the union
well let's focus now shall we on that
tragedy in the English Channel and also
the nurses strike that is due at start
tomorrow we can speak live now to the
health Minister uh Maria Caulfield who's
on the program for us uh today thank you
so much for being with us
um I just want to start on that tragedy
four people dying I mean it's literally
freezing out there in the dark I mean
how desperate would you have to be to
get on that boat well I think people are
desperate but also uh they're under
criminal gangs who are making thousands
of pounds uh per journey and I think as
the Home Secretary said in the House of
Commons today that's just a sheer
example of why we need to end this
practice there are legal routes into
this country uh which people can follow
we know that a lot of those people who
are traveling in the small boats are
economic migrants rather than seeking
Asylum are there legal Roots because I
know that there are safe and legal
routes if you're from Hong Kong or if
you're from Afghanistan or if you're
from Ukraine but is it true to say there
are legal routes into the UK to claim
Asylum Sue others from our humanitarian
perspective of you know since 2015 we've
taken over 400 000 people and you're
right for people from Ukraine uh people
from Afghanistan from Syria from Hong
Kong and the Prime Minister said when he
made his announcement at the dispatch
box
um yesterday that he's willing to look
at further safer legal routes in for
people who are claiming Asylum but we
have to deal with what's happening now
in the channel and we know that a
significant percentage of those are
economic migrants who are illegally
entering the country under uh the you
know the the rule of these people
traffickers and this is a classic
example of why we absolutely must end
this and as the Prime Minister said
enough is enough you appreciate though
that of course I don't think anyone will
dispute that there are economic migrants
as well but there are also people who
have faced persecution and there are no
safe and legal routes for many of the
people on the boat into the UK to claim
Asylum well I think we have been you
know extremely generous as a country and
I think that you know whether it's
people opening up their homes uh to
Ukrainian families uh this year or
whether it's taking in uh you know
people from Afghanistan and Hong Kong we
have shown that when people are facing
persecution or Terror that we absolutely
will take people in but some of people
that are coming through on the small
boats who are claiming Asylum they're
coming through many safe countries first
before they come here because they're a
note that's the point though isn't it
because there are no other ways of them
to claim assignment but there is no
reason how to be in the UK in order to
put that claim but there is no reason
why they have to come to the UK to claim
Asylum if you're traveling through
Germany and France uh to get here
there's no reason why you have to claim
asylum in the UK and the Prime Minister
has been clear he will look at safe and
legal routes but we cannot continue this
uh the numbers of people crossing in
those small boats we know it's putting
pressure on our Health Service on our
schools on housing and part of his
five-point plan is reducing the cost of
uh you know that we're currently
spending millions of pounds a day on
hotels and putting people up but you
know it's not fair on people who come
here legally that there are ways into
this country
um uh that you know are bypassing all
the rules I was having a look when I was
researching you know this interview
about the a percentage of Silent cases
that have been decided within six months
and I was pretty shocked actually it's
plummeted from over 80 percent in 2014
decided within six months to less than
10 percent in 2022 the turnover of
asylum caseworkers in 2021-22 was 40 I
mean what the Earth is going on this
looks like a system that's completely
broken well I think the the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary have
acknowledged the failings in the system
I think the Prime Minister was very
honest about that and has set up uh you
know the five-point plan where he wants
to get through the backlog of claims by
the end of next year that he's putting
extra resources into dealing with those
claims and then also that you know tough
reinforcement that you know if people
come here illegally they won't be able
to stay and return and claim to stay so
the backlog is one of the key areas of
his plan uh that we absolutely need to
to get through because it isn't fair on
those people who come here either to be
waiting you know sometimes years before
a decision is made if people have come
here illegally we need to assess their
claim and then there will be strict
enforcement in terms if they've got a
legal claim that will be upheld if not
then people can't just stay here but you
acknowledge that under conservative
governments the situation is not nowhere
near where it should be but I think
we've had two years of covid so let's
not uh pretend that we haven't had
problems
um in the last two years back from 2014.
yeah so so you so they have you know the
Prime Minister has acknowledged that
it's one of his key priorities to clear
the backlog by the end of next year
because that is one of the problems that
we've not been able to process the
claims as quickly as we'd like he said
that from the dispatch box that he
doesn't want to see this in months and
years he wants to see this in days and
weeks okay and now I want to talk to you
about the nurses strikes um you were a
nurse specializing in cancer treatment
at the Royal Marsden so you understand
more than most people What It's Like on
the front line with our hospitals I'm
sure many of your former colleagues
probably you know going out on strike
from tomorrow are they wrong too
um I personally don't support strike
action I'm I don't think their concerns
are wrong and I think you know I worked
uh during as a nurse during the the
cover pandemic I've worked shift since
as well so
um and dealing with the backlog caused
by covid is you know ex exceptionally
hard work
um what are their concerns then so pay
obviously is is one of those but I think
it's much more than pay I think it's
about the long hours that nurses work
often not finishing on time they don't
get protected Learning and Development
time like doctors do for example and
skill mix for example on the wards it
can be it's not just about numbers on
the walls it's the level experience and
skills that are available too so when
I've met with Pat Cullen for example
they're the sorts of issues that the
Secretary of State wants to talk about
in terms of improving the working
conditions of nurses and pay is just a
tiny element and I think the strike
action is more about um from talking to
my colleagues is more about their
frustration about working conditions
rather than pay itself so even though
you don't you say you don't personally
agree with strong action you've got
sympathy for what I think nurses have
you know have had a a very difficult
time I don't think anyone's denying that
I just don't see what's striking uh
achieves I'm very much you know Keen to
work with Pat and the RCN to look at
those conditions as is the Secretary of
State when he met with her this week but
we cannot meet the demands of a 19 pay
rate just talking um you know about
um Pat Cullen in about the meeting with
Steve Barkley because she was pretty
disparaging about what came at that
meeting she said that Steve Barkley
showed belligerence he refused to
discuss pay he was nothing short of
disrespectful I also thought it was
interesting to say that she thought the
government was displaying Macho Behavior
towards the RCM because it sees nursing
as female work that it doesn't value
properly I mean it doesn't sound like
you know she really believes the house
secretary has got her back well I'm
sorry Pat feels like that you know I
know Pat very well and she's a you know
very good uh leader of the RCN and I got
nothing but respect for Pat but we have
to be honest that we cannot afford the
19 pay rise demand that they're um
they're wanting that will cost us 10
billion pounds
um and you know as the Prime Minister
said the dispatch box today
because there has been some questions
marks about that figure hasn't it it's
important to say and you know the ifs
say you know the government's sakes a
thousand pounds household that ifs says
more like 640 pounds the thousand pounds
per household is if it was at inflation
for all the public sector uh because we
know what would happen if we if if the
nurses get an above and play inflation
pay rise of course the ambulance workers
will want it of course teachers will
work want it so you know this is about
if we've got an independent pay review
body in place that looks at factors such
as inflation School shortages
Recruitment and Retention they come up
with a pay recommendation which the
government has accepted in full so you
obviously think that 90 is unaffordable
um nurses are generally often been
offered around four percent NHS Scotland
is offering 7.5 percent still below
inflation but more generous than the
current thing the current offer on the
table for those in NHS England and Wales
what would be a fair pay rise for nurses
well we we feel that the end dependent
pay review body to take the politics out
of four percent so and that decision was
made some nurses are getting more than
that so the those on the lowest lower
agenda for change paying some of them
are getting close to nine percent but
the average is it's a recommendation
isn't it though I mean you could overall
it if you wanted and four percent at a
time when inflation figures out this
morning are 10.7 I mean people are
struggling to put food on the table here
aren't they you can see there's been
stories about nurses being forced to use
food banks we could overrule it but in
order to pay for that we can only pay
for that in three ways the first is to
borrow money and we saw just a few weeks
ago when the government borrows money it
can't afford what happens to interest
rates and uh to the market we could tax
people more because it's not the
government's money it's taxpayers money
at the end of the day we could raise
taxes to pay for that I don't think
anyone wants us to do that or take it
within existing budgets and that's quite
a lot of money at a time we're trying to
clear those covered backlogs it would
mean taking it away from the surgical
hubs whether developing communities
Gnostic centers you know the the
recruiting say for example in mental
health uh 27 000 extra staff that that's
where that money will have to come from
and as a minister as a government we
have to make those tough choices
um and if we've set up an independent
pay with you body then we feel we need
to honor that
um and uh you know we're taking those
factors into consideration and we're
fully uh implemented that pay review
bodies recommendation I just want to
have a look at the comparison between
the private sector what's happening the
private sector and what's happening in
the public sector because the ons says
that pay growth in the private sector is
6.6 versus 2.2 percent in the public
sector and you can see there uh private
sector pay at going up more uh
generously than public sector pay you
know
government ministers often say that you
know we're having to stomach this pain
in order to try and beat inflation but
if your work in the public sector you
might be feeling it's a bit unfair why
should you be the one who's having to
Bear the brunt of the pain and you look
at the more generous rise has been
giving in the private sector so there
are there are other benefits to being a
public sector worker other than uh pay
uh you know your job security is much
more stable pay your energy bill well it
does if you're in the public sector if
you're working in retail or Commerce and
you know in the hospitality sector for
example where they're reducing people's
hours because people aren't going out to
eat and drink as they would normally
with the train Stripes people aren't
going shopping like they they would do
normally there's a lot more job in
security if you're in the private sector
you also don't necessarily get the same
sick pay maternity leave benefits that
you do or pension benefits that you do
in the public sector so you know and as
I said earlier pay is only one small
part of most nurses um concerns about
working life at the moment when you talk
to to many of them who are thinking of
reducing hours or leaving actually pay
is probably one of the last things that
they actually mention it's the long
hours it's the hard work it's the skill
mix on the walls we can do something and
we are doing something about that and
pay is just one small consideration in
that okay thanks very much for being on
the program uh good to talk to you about
two very serious subjects uh today or we
can get some immediate reaction from the
nurses Union the woman that we've been
talking about a little bit in that
interview uh the Royal College of
Nursing Pat Cullen and the union says
that its members will be walking out
tomorrow and it wants direct pay
negotiations with the government well
let's speak now shall we too uh the
general secretary and chief executive
Pat Cullen thank you very much for being
with me uh today we've just heard from
Maria Caulfield who says that the
strikes aren't really about pay they're
only a small element about paying it's
more about conditions is that right
so it has an absolutely not true and I
heard Maria describe
um in quite a disparaging way pay has
just been a tiny thing and for our
nursing staff our nursing staff are on
the breadline they're not able to afford
their bills there are some of them
aren't even able to afford travel to get
to their work for goodness sake and yet
we have a minister sitting here saying
that it's about all of the other things
and not about pay that is absolutely not
true of course there are many other
terms and conditions we would like this
government to sort out for our nurses
absolutely but pay is fundamental if we
are going to try and keep the nurses
we've got in the Health Service and try
and recruit more than 50 000 vacancies
in this country and if we don't address
pay then I'm afraid I most nurses would
say to you tonight they are fearful for
where the Health Service will end up
right let's talk about pay then shall we
let's talk about numbers
um you open negotiations asking for 19
at pay rise at five percent above
inflation the government said that's
unaffordable what would you accept
I said we'd get around your table and
talk about this uh but I heard you
mention about the meeting that I had
with um Steve Barclay a few days back
and once again brought into a room and
told you can talk about anything you
wish to talk to me about but we will not
be talking about pay on until I can get
into a room and talk about pay to the
ministers then I'm afraid I'm not going
to negotiate for the hundreds of
thousands of nurses that will be on
picket lines tomorrow over there with
but they owe those nurses
um everything to get into your room and
start to talk about pay surely to
goodness that's the only respectful
thing they could do at this stage
instead or instead of what they're doing
they are allowing those hundreds of
thousands of nurses to actually go on to
picket lines tomorrow and stand out in
the cold when they want to be inside
looking after their patients but this is
kind of the point though isn't it
because you've said yourself that the
health secretary isn't talking to you
about numbers
um and yet the government is making a
huge play the fact that you want a 19
pay rise they clearly feel that that
plays into their hands that most people
listening will think it's unaffordable
so surely this is your opportunity to
give a bit of guidance on what you would
accept so in Scotland for example uh
there's been an accepted offer of 7.5
percent would you accept that
look we had an opportunity to stop the
spin and start to speak a few days ago I
was very optimistic going to that
meeting hoping that at least we would
have some sense shown
um and then we could actually have
stopped the strike tomorrow but in fact
that was never going to be on the cards
for this government they brought us into
a room they marched us up to the top of
the hill again and they abandoned our
nursing staff the 320 000 nurses that
have voted for for us for strike action
that's an incredible and significant
mandate and you cannot ignore their
voices you absolutely cannot they're not
asking for uh as I keep saying their
pockets to be lined with gold they're
wanting a decent decent wage that isn't
they're entitled to a decent wage and if
we are going to try and address the
issues within our Health Service we need
to retain our nurses that we've got in
the Health Service those nurses that
Maria talked about today on your program
that are not able to get their annual
leave they're not able they're working
every R that's available to them to keep
the Health Service going and actually
when you talk about the 19 we never
asked for 19 in February of this year we
submitted our evidence to the peer
review body and at that point inflation
was not sitting where it is now and then
in July uh the the government accepted
the recommendation of the peer review
body I never accepted the
recommendations nor did our nurses and
inflation wasn't where it is now either
and so the more they've tried their head
is the longer they've tried their Haze
and flashing has continued to rise and
consequently we're sitting at 19 but
what I would say to Maria and to Steve
Barkley and any other minister listening
can you afford not to do this and indeed
the international Council of nurses
wrote to Steve Barkley this evening and
told them plainly and squarely that he
cannot afford not to do it either so as
you're saying you never have asked for
90 just this is your chance though to
clear it up and I know you know I
understand what you're saying about you
know you don't want to negotiate on the
Airways but I do feel as well but you
know nurses are going on strike the
public have a right to know exactly what
it is you're striking for I just don't
understand why you won't be a bit more
specific on what kind of pay rise you
think would be you know Fair
no I'm definitely not going to negotiate
on the airwaves and I don't think that
any Minister should reduce or a
profession to have to do that they
should they should do the decent thing
and get into a room and they go see it
with me I've also said if they find that
that maybe isn't isn't suitable for them
that we will do it through conciliation
and engage with aircasts I don't think
that's very much for our profession to
ask and I don't think that any Minister
should suggest or ask that we would
negotiate on Airways and not give us the
respect to get into a room with us uh
okay
um if the government doesn't uh do what
you're asking to you get around the
table negotiate on pay should we expect
to see more nurses strikes
well the the
um the balls in their Court quite
frankly uh there will be a second day on
the 20th of December and unless we have
um talks and unless we are able to
negotiate on behalf of my members then
I'm afraid to say that that's that's a
very strong possible deal already we
will be starting to look at when those
debts will be
so what kind of time frame would be you
saying you'll be looking at what when
that could be what kind of time frame
are we looking at then potentially
I'm afraid that they will continue into
January okay that's a really interesting
uh to hear uh certainly uh something uh
sobering as well if you look at the
current waiting times operations in the
NHS and what do you think the impacts of
the strikes will be
well just when you mentioned waiting
lists I think that's a really important
point
um why are those nurses going on picket
lines tomorrow and losing a day's pay
out of the meager salaries that they
that this government has
um insisted that they live on that they
can't live on actually
uh but our waiting lists are at 7.3
million uh people in this country
waiting year on year of wearing just
languishing on waiting lists and why are
they because we haven't got the nurses
to be able to care and treat those
patients so the ministers will continue
to talk about if we take money from
um the elective care waiting lists and
and give it to the nurses then we won't
be able to attract and address the
elective care waiting lists but you'll
address new waiting lists if you do not
have the nursing staff to actually care
and treat those patients they're
actually one of the same thing so this
is again all part of the spin that's put
on this about taking from patients and
given to nurses it's nurses that look
after patients and without nursing staff
patients in this country are getting a
pretty Raw Deal sitting on waiting list
year after year when their treatments
should be given to them at a time when
they require them and then they can get
on and live their fruitful and normal
lives and and continue to contribute to
society when in fact because of the ill
health and the increases in the real
health and their chronic conditions they
can't do that so everything leads back
everything leads back to paying nurses a
decent wage and ensuring we can recruit
staff into the Health Service and retain
those nurses we've got I was quite
struck by some comments that you made
after the meeting with Steve Barkley you
said that you thought the government was
displaying particularly Metro Behavior
towards the Royal College of Nursing
because it sees nursing as female work
and doesn't value it properly do you
think there is some sexism in the way
that nurses are treated
I absolutely do and in fact again I
refer back to the international Council
and for nurses and they have addressed
that in the letter to Steve Barkley this
evening as well so it's a well-known
fact that nursing staff is at 90 female
profession
and if you think of some of the things
that this government has um done over
this last number of weeks uh I have to
ask
um them would they do that if those if
those statistics were different if we
were not a 90 female profession
so just one example where they have
decided that the military can come in
and uh with a few hours of training and
take on the role of a nurse take on the
role of caring for patients and there's
not a single nurse in this country would
suggest that with a few hours training
that they could go out and put on a
military uniform and take a gun and do
what our military does because they
absolutely could not and but yet it
seems to be that the value of caring is
brought down to the lowest common
denominator and it can be done by anyone
with a few hours training and that's
just so wrong if you look at what the
government has done with saying they're
going to put in more Draconian
legislation to ensure that through their
trade unions nursing cannot have a voice
that's about trying to silence those
nurses the 90 90 female profession that
we are and I could go on there's many
more examples that I could use but I'm
not alone in thinking this then
International Council of nurses believe
it as well and indeed the people that I
represent believe it okay thank you very
much for being on the program uh today
Pat Cullen there at the RCN saying uh
that those strikes uh could be going on
into January if there isn't a resolution
well a bit later on we'll get Labor's
take on all of that but let's have a
quick chat to our Deputy political
editor at Sam Coates first at shall we
uh Sam I thought it was pretty
interesting to hear Pat Colin there
being pretty clear that if there is no
resolution and it doesn't feel like
there is any move towards that right now
we should expect more strikes in the new
year and it's not just news to strikes
in the nursing sector I think across the
other uh sectors that are facing
industrial action that's the talk at the
moment whether it's rail uh or elsewhere
and I think that from the two interviews
that you've done so far this evening
Sophie there are there are clear themes
there are two big challenges that Rishi
cnax government is actually quite Keen
to talk about one is Asylum and
migration and the other is how they're
going to handle uh strikes both at the
moment look incredibly difficult for
ministers but I think number 10 thinks
that they plan on both of them when it
comes to migration there was the plan
announced by Richie sunac earlier this
week which will see tough new laws in
order to prevent anybody coming in
illegally from staying when it comes to
strike there is the strikes uh it looks
as if the government's going to
introduce new minimum standards and
potentially go further
but there's a big but so if you want
number 10 might be pleased with
themselves for getting away from that
sense of growing rolling chaos and
focusing on two issues of policy both of
those will be incredibly difficult to
deliver when it's when it comes to
migration and boats there's a question
of if there are not legal routes for
Asylum Seekers to come into the country
how is that policy workable and then
when it comes to potentially Banning
nurses from ever striking all members of
some other professions that is an
enormous removal of a right to strike
that people have at the moment and if
you take the police sector for instance
and they actually play the police more
precisely because well maybe they're not
in a union but they cannot strike so are
we going to pay nurses more after all as
we take away their their right to strike
I don't think any of that's going to
happen when it comes to legislation
expect stuff weaker to get it through
quicker but nothing is going to happen
in a hurry really interesting uh to talk
and as you say you know they couldn't
have the policy decisions but whether or
not things follow and they get the
results that come in from that is a
whole nother question thanks very much
Sam uh you're watching uh the take we're
live here in Westminster for you this
evening up next we'll be talking to
Labor's Shadow Financial secretary to
the treasury James Murray
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take let's get
labels take now at shall we on what
we've been discussing uh this evening so
far especially of course that tragedy in
the channel we can speak now to the
shadow Financial secretary to the
treasury James Murray who joins us on
the program today thank you so much for
coming into the studio this evening
um I just want to talk about what
happened in the English Channel
um four people dead the freezing Waters
the dark the the phone call that was
made in the early hours of the morning I
mean it's impossible not to look at the
details and be very moved by it what
would labor do
you're right when we talk about the
details when you hear about what
happened it's it's horrific there's no
other word for it it's truly you know
deeply upsetting and and awful to to
hear what happened and you know I think
it really it should be a wake-up call
it's really underscores the fact that we
need to do something about people who
are being smuggled with white people
traffickers uh by criminal gangs across
the the channel
um now you know we know that there's
been a lot of discussion about this um
in the media and so on and in Parliament
you know we've been saying for a long
time that rather than spend money on
things like the Rwanda policy which we
think is unethical and unworkable that
money would be better spent beefing up
the capacity the National Crime agency
to go after the criminal gangs who are
smuggling these people in the first
place it's easy Southern done though
isn't it you know if it was easy to
break up the people with traffickers
then yeah any government would do that
wouldn't they I mean I just look at what
Interpol says on that you know there's a
relatively low risk of detection
prosecution and arrest compared to other
activities of translation National
organized crime and it's because the
relationship between the criminals and
the migrants as the temporary ones the
criminals are really hard to trace
they're unknown to the people they're
smuggling that you know they hide behind
sedanims they use Rental Vehicles
different mobile numbers I mean if
Labor's not going to just be able to
just you know bang a bit more money to
the National Crime agency and suddenly
it's all going to be sorted well hard
problems are what government has to deal
with you know hard problems whether it's
what we're discussing now or the really
other big issues like the climate
emergency or all of the other challenges
that we face it is government's job
ultimately to take on these difficult
issues and yes it's not the case of just
snapping your fingers and making things
go right you know it does require hard
work Focus rolling up your sleeves
sitting down at the table making sure
that you're really delivering the
program that you talk about and you know
it is one of the wider problems not just
in relation to this issue but across the
piece so the government members of
government members of the conservative
party are so distracted by their own
internal Party politics Works within
parliament in trying to hang on to their
jobs and doing all of their their horse
trading and worried about rebellions
here and there they're not focused on
delivering the job which is which is
tackling the really big issues we Face
let's focus on what labor would do um
would you open more routes to people to
claim Asylum legally in the UK because
obviously one of the issues is that
there aren't very many safe and legal
routes if you're not from one of the
sort of designated countries that has
them like Hong Kong Ukraine and
Afghanistan would you like to see it
easier for people to claim Asylum so we
need to make some really important
changes around for instance replacing
the Dublin agreement making sure that
that is there for a safe reunions family
reunions and so on I think the other
part of the of the equation which is
really important as well though is to
make sure that when people are in the UK
the applications are processed and
fairly but speedily and this is one of
the really big problems the UK isn't it
that's the thing because at the minute
it's you can't get to the UK in a safe
and legal route right if you're going to
only be able to claim Asylum when you're
in the UK that's why I come over on a
small boat exactly and that's one of the
problems that the Home Secretary you
know found very difficult
well at the recent hearing that the Home
Secretary had you know she wasn't able
to explain how the policies which the
conservatives are proposing that would
help people to make applications and
safe routes into the country and what we
know is you need those safe and legal
routes but you also need to make sure
that you have the investment here so
that the Asylum applications can be
processed and if they're and and quick
way because you know at the moment if we
see people in hotel accommodation for
months years on end that's bad for the
people involved it racks up the bill in
terms of paying for that accommodation
and it's bad for the overall system okay
we've just heard from uh Pat Cullen of
the Royal College of Nursing saying that
if there isn't a resolution then we can
expect strikes continuing into the new
year into January which obviously is
going to be
um you know desperate news for the NHS
and it's already under pressure
nurses have said they want a pay rise
that's five percent above inflation is
that affordable
well as um the shadow Secretary of State
for health and and others and the
opposition has said you know that that
19 you know is not going to be
affordable but the point is uh there
should be a negotiation about avoiding
these strikes going ahead about coming
to a resolution and you know if you take
a step back and think how the government
have behaved in relation to the nurses
and other NHS workers and indeed
different sectors across the across the
economy and across public the public
sector the government have not been
willing to negotiate they have stepped
back they have let these problems uh
develop or go without the solution and
actually as I said in in response to one
of your earlier questions the job of
government is to roll up your sleeves
and try and sort out difficult problems
and this is a difficult problem but it
is one where we believe the government
should roll up their sleeves get get to
the negotiating table and avoid these
strikes that no one wants to see happen
you know the nurses don't want them to
go ahead would you like to see the labor
government in Wales do that then as well
where there's also Stripes going on well
we want to see across the country three
strikes averted you know and the point
is
the way that you avert strikes is to
negotiate with trade unions with workers
representatives and try and get a deal
because no one wants strikes to go ahead
you know the nurses do not want to go on
strike no one in any industry wants to
go on strike and as it and the public
don't want to see the strikes either it
really is the job of government rather
than standing back rather than giving up
because it's too hard rather than
threatening you know new legislation to
to to as they would see it deal with the
problem they need to roll up their
sleeves to sit down at their table
negotiate a solution well I mean I guess
the government would say they've said
what the offer is because they're going
to go along with the pay review body
which is around four percent for most
nurses so so what would Labor's position
be then so ultimately it is the
responsibility of government to find a
solution
you're the government in Waiting what
would be a fair pay rise for nurses
would it be 7.5 like they've accepted in
Scotland well the point of having a
negotiation is that you have that
negotiation to work out what the the pay
deal is and what the other terms of
their agreement are but if you're in a
position you can get a bit of pressure
on the government by saying what your
position would be the the position that
we're putting the pressure on the
government to do is to negotiate is to
get around the table and to roll up
their sleeves and do the the difficult
but critical work of government which
has come to a solution and that's how we
would avert strikes and that's how we'd
make sure that the health services is a
better position but you know if we can
just say one other one other point which
is really important which is that the
Health Service you know has been run
down it's been run down for 12 years and
pays a really important issue but it's
also a lack of lack of Staff you know
there's real problems with Recruitment
and Retention which is why we proposed
the biggest expansion of the NHS
Workforce in its history funded by
scrapping for non-dong tax status okay
thank you very much for being on the
program uh today explaining some of
Labor's proposals James Murray uh there
time now to take a closer look at
today's prime minister's questions and
of course the news of those deaths in
the English Channel overshadowed
proceedings but it was the strikes that
were focused on by kirst armor here's
what our political correspondent Joe
Pike made of all in pmq's unwrapped
today's session started with tributes to
those caught up in the English Channel
migrant tragedy
Mr Speaker I'm sure the whole house will
share my sorrow at the capsizing of a
small boat in the channel in the early
hours of this morning and the tragic
loss of human life it's a reminder that
the criminal gangs running those routes
put the lives of the desperate at risk
and profit from their misery they must
be broken up and brought to Justice
tomorrow members of the Royal College of
Nursing will go on strike for the first
time in their history so today kirst
armor chose to focus on that industrial
action and attempted to argue it's the
government's fault for not negotiating
all the prime minister has to do to stop
that is to open the door and discuss pay
with them after 12 years of Tory failure
winter has arrived for our public
services and we've got a prime minister
who has curled up in a ball and gone
into hibernation
[Applause]
now kirst Armor's team believed that
because strikes are so widespread
because voters know life is tough and
the cost of living is real there is an
instinctive resonance with the plight of
Strikers in contrast to Richie sunax
allies argue that sakir is yet again
ignoring reality to score political
points The Honorable gentleman says to
get round the table but we all know what
that means Mr Speaker that is just
simply a political formula for avoiding
taking a position on this
on the pay demands of 19 are met then he
should say so and it all soon descended
into familiar and not entirely relevant
territory
she's too weak to stand up for tax
avoiders he's not strong enough to stand
up to the union but as usual Mr Speaker
he tries to blame everyone else if we'd
listened to him Mr Speaker the backlog
would still be growing and that's
because we'd still be in lockdown
kirst Armor's final question of the
final pmqs this year focused on a point
of policy agreement the war in Ukraine
Millions will spend Christmas in
Sub-Zero temperatures without heating
electricity or hot water their suffering
is unimaginable but their bravery is
awe-inspiring this Christmas many
families will be laying an extra place
at their Christmas table and that speaks
to the generosity and compassion of our
nation and long may that continue
throughout today's questions there was a
festive feel but with a distinctly Bleak
Outlook ordinary families are facing a
dickensian nightmare across the country
this Christmas we know it's Christmas
but the past is not started yeah this
year the Tory party has given us five
education secretaries four chancellors
three prime ministers two leadership
[Applause]
thank you
and me and Mr Speaker The Partridge just
had to sell the pear tree to pay the
castle
[Laughter]
yet another year of political Perma
crisis MPS seem desperate for their
Christmas break pmqs is back in four
weeks time and all the same challenges
the war in Ukraine the NHS public sector
pay seemed sure to feature again
well Jerry was mentioning the Christmas
outbreak there and it does feel doesn't
it but it's a good point because it's
our last show of the year as well we're
back in early uh January to reflect
on what a year it's been it's been
extraordinary hasn't it so let's bring
in our viewers panel at this point shall
we I asked them to have a little think
about who their politician of the year
is so now it's time to find out I'm
gonna get a Vic first Vic Daniels a
conservative voting talking to us we're
from West London now Vic you've got
three politicians of the year but you've
told Jared our producer that you're
going to sell all of it in 60 seconds so
that's your challenge who's your
politician of the Year all right
okay so let's trust
who famously said on between the Prime
Minister I'm ready to hit the ground on
day one
and she did
Matt Hancock
buying his political Masters and going
into the jungle
diving and thriving there uh dealing
with the new book out
enhanced her career perspective and a
love-hate relationship with Boy George
to sum up the year as Boris does on the
leading office them was the breaks and
on the final show of the year
hasta la vista
baby
amazing I think that was a pretty uh
short and sweet have to say and it what
a year it's been it did kind of sum up
the roller coaster it definitely right
let's bring in Mike rumro next shall we
uh you are a swing voter perhaps more to
the right you're talking to us from
Hampshire who's your politician of the
year
well you may think I'm more left when I
when I
can you read that message
he um
in interviews I've seen him in he's very
competent handling the ridiculous
nonsense that politicians throw it
um
he he just doesn't accept what he came
up with and we've just heard waffle from
me
Health minister
total just just parroting some kind of
policy that means nothing doesn't
achieve an end
well I have to say he's certainly been
one of the political characters of the
year I think perhaps lots of us weren't
familiar with Nick wrench at this time
last year that's certainly it could be
said to be the case now right let's
bring in is our batashoggi now at shall
we describe yourself as a libder labor
voter you're talking to us from London
who's your politician of the year
I wrote down
Liz Trump
but not in a good way
uh I think
be precipitated
massive economics yeah
and
um
you know
it does feel doesn't it like Liz trust
makes me one of those politicians that
we will always remember it kind of feels
like you're living through history uh
the shortest service ever uh prime
minister uh Belinda Campbell uh swing
voter talking to us from Twickenham in
West London who's your politician of the
year
yeah
because he comes across as very
authentic there's emotions he shows them
really well I can feel his frustration
he speaks for the people he doesn't give
up
um he really trusts Place points across
with a lot of emotion and they're
believable
interesting stuff I thought there might
be a curious armor at somewhere today
let's talk to Bruce Tyler next shall we
conservative voter from East Riding of
Yorkshire who did you go for
foreign
but
um my choice is uh Jeremy Hunt
um I think he uh stepped up to the plate
to do the job when many would not have
done
um would be interested to know whether
uh other people were asked before him
but um he's done a great job stepping
into the the void and preventing the
economy descending uh Into the Depths
um we saw Sterling descend to one dollar
and three cents we saw the two-year
yield on on guilts descenders sorry
increased to 4.7 percent
both of those have been turned around by
20 since then and the economy is
stabilized and I think he's uh he's done
a very very good job in doing that it
does feel like we're learning a bit more
about just how close things got with
their Pension funds at that point
doesn't it a really interesting analysis
uh there right let's finally go to
aroica's St John Mild May you're sent to
left photo and you're talking to us from
Norfolk who is your politician of the
Year well
um that is Theresa May and I am left
leaning and I'm I think actually the
conservatives are mostly very dense and
unresponsive to the needs of the country
um but in the spirit of respect and
appreciation of even Christmas I do
nominate
Theresa May because
he did something seven years ago which
was he brought in coercive in the
trouble Behavior into the legal
framework of domestic abuse as
um section 76 and the domestic violence
um crime act and now it's entered common
parlance and and and understanding
amongst loads of potential victims
before they get dragged under and so you
know I didn't say that she was like the
woman of the moment but but actually
what she did before okay has come
to life so I say Merry Christmas Mrs May
I'm I'm not observed to voter by by but
you are going in after four Theresa May
uh really interesting uh to hear all of
your views great range there uh Teresa
made us one of uh three uh former
conservative prime ministers on the back
benches we're in Westminster next up
we'll be rounding up everything we just
heard with Sam Coates
[Music]
from the very beginning of this big war
since March myself and many other
Ukrainian politicians were promoting one
very simple and clear narrative
a big part of Ukrainian Victory is not
just defeating Russians on Ukrainian
soil but bringing into accountability
everyone who committed war crimes in
Ukraine because without Justice based on
international law it's important to
expect peaceful and comfortable future
for this very moment it's not my wish
it's a giant Consolidated view of G7
just two days ago G7 spread its latest
communique and let me quote there can be
no impunity for war crimes and other
atrocities we will call President Putin
and those responsible to account in
accordance with international law so
it's not my wish anymore it's not the
wish of president zielinski or all other
ukrainians that's the Consolidated
understanding of the west but the
challenge is not only to bring Russian
leadership to accountability but to
bring into accountability everyone who
committed work Brands and at the moment
I can report to you that Ukrainian
officials registered more than 70
000 crimes related to racial aggression
more than 50 000 work crimes has been
detected by a Ukrainian law enforcement
all that require absolutely huge efforts
from
prosecutors from experts from
investigators and definitely it's a huge
task for Ukrainian judicial system and
for Ukrainian Georges because it's
understood for today that yes top
Russian leaders will brought into
prosecution through International
tribunal Court I hope so I recently came
back from Hague and international
criminal recordings a is working
extremely hard to have a good result
with this but all these thousands of
work Brands definitely will be
considered by Ukrainian courts well Ray
they are doing this the the training of
Ukrainian and judges is extremely
important because no one in this world
has enough capabilities and enough
experience to proceed with such a huge
amount of work right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Westminster watching uh
the take we've just been hearing what
our viewers panel made of uh the year
but it's right to I think reflect shall
we uh with Sam our Deputy political
editor and Sam we've covered some pretty
extraordinary years in British politics
recently but I mean this year has been
just
utterly flabbergasting hasn't it what
are your moments of the year
I think there are three to mention in
particular let's look at the first one
now we spent a lot of the first six
months talking about parties but here's
the thing Sophie I don't think parties
eventually did for Boris Johnson who was
ousted just before the summer I think it
was he was in a very Rocky position even
this time last year in the end it was a
different Scandal about a Minister's
misconduct that got him over the edge so
this might be remembered but was it the
really important moment perhaps not
um because there was so much else this
year if we look at the next one
you've got Jeremy Hunt and actually the
really turbulent period this year was
Liz truss's Premiership and this is the
moment where Jeremy Hunt reversed the
mini budget that got her into all that
trouble many assumed many still believe
that was a political act but we now know
that that morning it turned out there
was a financial firm a pension firm
about to go under that is why they did
it and here is Boris Johnson coming back
after Liz tress has defenestrated to try
and become leader here's the thing we've
learned this week I've learned this week
I don't think he ever really had the
numbers he didn't get over a hundred
people who uniquely signed up to his
campaign that's the belief amongst some
on the 1922. it really feels with
everything moving so quickly we're
almost learning history as it goes thank
you so much uh Sam that's it for the
take it's been a lot of fun to follow
this year with you we'll be back in
January
foreign
[Music]